Erica Wernick, Author/Coach: You have these two
lists side by side. You've got all the fears
and doubts and then you've got the opposite,
essentially affirmations of the new beliefs. I
always say when you look at these two lists
side by side if you looked at them as two
different people (Person A and Person B) what
kind of career would person A have? This list
of fears and doubts that's their belief system.
What kind of career do you think they're going
to have and it's usually well they probably
won't get very far they're probably going to
struggle and then what about person B? These
affirmations this new belief system what kind
of career do you think they're going to
have you know it's usually they're gonna
kick butt they're gonna do great and the whole
point of this is not to say you can never have
these fears again you know I think the doubts and
the fears they're always going to be there they
might change over time the point is we want
the second list to be in the driver's seat
so the fears and doubts it's okay to have them
they're still going to hang out in the back seat
of the car but we want the affirmations the
new list the new beliefs driving the show.